President Trump is seriously considering
have a United States by Greenland and so
as you can imagine a lot of people have
been kind of making fun of this idea the
past day or so but not me
you see I want to give President Trump
the benefit of the doubt what if we the
United States did buy Greenland it might
just be a good idea it seriously might
and as the elder statesman of late night
what if I negotiated the deal seriously
what if I handled this historic
negotiation okay I have as much if not
more negotiating experiences Trump I
mean seriously come on I do I really do
I mean come on an 11 o'clock time slot
on TBS you don't just get that ladies in
time
now Liz Lerman Greenland is a territory
of Denmark and the Danish Prime Minister
said Greenland is not for sale
but if there's anything I've learned
from watching hundreds of hours of
property brothers saying it's not for
sale is the classic opening gambit that
means you're ready to go yeah definitely
for sale and ladies and gentlemen if we
don't move fast some other country is
gonna overpay for it
yeah China that looky-loo is gonna come
in all cash snatch it up so all right
Denmark you want to play hardball I'm
ready to sweeten the deal there's a
couple of ways we could do it first we
could do a straight trade Greenland for
Florida okay yeah trust me this is our
best state and please do not Google
Florida not convinced yet how about this
Greenland once your party United States
you'll be enrolled in the US healthcare
system that's right yeah also please do
not Google US health care system wait
Greenland Greenland battling the coal is
one of your greatest concerns
well after your joining this country
you'll never be cold again because
you'll be American fat the greatest fat
in the world and one final thing if this
deal wasn't good enough we'll get rid of
Ozz guard cuz everybody hates that creep
cosgard
legend when you watch the show on TV
tonight that little joke won't be in
there yeah it really is true
nobody likes us no one really likes
Sarsgaard or jokes about a guy and ours
guard what a dick
yeah
and here's the best part to make sure
this purchase goes through I count on a
Brian I'm gonna personally travel to
Greenland
okay I'm gonna be the first American
host to visit Greenland since Arsenio
Hall did a week of shows there in 1989
that's right yeah it was a great week
fantastic week you see that week I know
Bell Biv DeVoe was on that's right I'll
be look it up that's right I'll be
headed there as part of Conan Without
Borders and you can follow me proko.com
yeah gonna be an amazing trip and here's
my promise if I do not make this deal to
purchase Greenland if I do not make this
deal i Conan O'Brien will never ever
again step foot on American soil
you